Good morning everybody. I am Eddy and
I'm another TA for this
functional programming course.
Today we're gonna look at an exercise
about higher order functions,
namely an exercise about Church Numerals.
When we think about the representation
of a number,
we can see that we can represent a
number in many different ways.
We can represent it using decimals
like 123. We can represent it using binary
notation, so only using zeros and ones,
but we can also represented in many
other ways for example with the
with a string of stars
in which each star represents a unit.
When we talk about Church numerals
we talk about a way to abstract
over this
concrete representation of a number
by means of functions and function
definition.
Now let's see how a Church numeral works.
The type of the Church numeral is this,
that you can see
here on the slide.
It's basically a function that
takes as
input argument another function namely
we will see that this function is called
the successor function
it takes another element, another
argument which is this the zero number
and it returns the Church representation
of this number.
Ideally a number n
is defined as n applications of the
successor function
over the zero number. Now let's try to
actually
write this type of number so that we see
more or less
how they look like. We said they are
represented as a function that takes as an
input parameter
an s and a z
and for example the zero representation
returns only
the zero number. For the
representation of one we apply the successor
function
only one time, for the representation of
two
we apply twice. Now we can see that
since we are Haskall programmers, we don't
like
a lot of noise in our code.
We can refactor our representation of
two
by using the composition operator
so then we can write s . s and
then
using a technique that comes from
lambda calculus namely called eta
reduction.
We can remove the z argument
and just the show
this implementation of two, which is
exactly the same from the first one.
These are the representation on the Church numerals.
As you can see from the type the
a tells us that they are polymorphic.
What does this mean?
This means that we can instantiate
them
to represent a number in any concrete
representation and this is what we're
saying
from the beginning. Therefore this a can
become
integer, can become a string, can become
anything else. Let's try now to write
some functions that actually instantiate
these Church numerals to concrete
representations. For example lets write
a function
Church to Int. This function will take as
an input argument
a Church representation of a
number, therefore a function,
and will apply to this a successor function
that would be only the
plus one and a zero number that would
be zero.
We can he see here an example
so the first argument is
two and then we apply to this +1 and 0.
Once we substitute we see that we apply +1 to 0
the first time. Once we have done this
we will apply +1 to the result of
that, which will be 1,
which will give us 2 in the end.
As I said we can instantiate
this function not only to integers but
to other things as well.
For example we can do for our example with strings
from before. The successor function
will append
to the String (the head of the
String) the star
and the zero operator will be
the empty string. Here you can see an
example in the slide and again
we apply this to the number 2 and
we see that
first we
cons a star
to the empty string and then we cons
again to the result of that which
will be the string containing only the
star,
only one star. We will cons again
another star and
we will have the representation of two.
Up until now we have
described what a Church numeral is
and we have described how to instantiate
it
to a concrete representation but
what we have to do now is we need
to define operations over
these numbers so that we can
actually
manipulate them. To do this we will try
now to
derive an implementation of addition.
We start by
taking two definitions: we have
x' and y' which are
Church to Int of x and y. So x and y are
Church
numerals and their Church to Int version is
an integer.
What we want to achieve in our derivation
is that the integer addition of
x and y equals
Church to Int of a function that we will
define: add x y
defined over Church
numerals. Okay, to do this
let's start easily, so we say
x' + y' just equals
the representation from here: Church
to Int of x
plus Church to Int of y.
Now we expand the first definition
Church to Int of x
with our implementation of Church to Int
so we'll apply to x the
successor function +1 and the zero
number 0. Now what we can see
is that here we are building up zero
starting from zero number which we gave
ourselves which is zero,
but then we say
after this we want to add another
integer which is the integer
presentation of y.
So why don't we just start building x
instead of from zero from the integer
representation a y itself?
Okay, we can see that by generalizing
a little the Church to Int function this
is really easy. If the Church to Int
function will take another parameter z
we can substitute the zero
to a parameter defined by the user and
so we can
get this Church to Int and move
it inside as the base number of the
representation of x.
What to do now is we expand
Church to Int of y again with the
same definition of Church to Int
and what we can do now is that
we have two instances of
the +1 function and then
one time
we can find the zero number.
Why don't we get those, we abstract them out
with another trick from lambda
calculus
which is called beta expansion and we
create a function out of that.
This is this step: here I have
highlighted the
+1 and successor and all the names
so that the it's easier to understand
what we have basically done here is we
have
expanded that term that we have,
that expression,
into a function that is then applied to
+1 and 0.
So these two terms in the last two
lines are exactly the same.
What to do now is we can get
this lambda
and we can give it a name just because
it's easier for us to see.
So let's call it add. Now I will explain
one second why add but
let's call it add and we see
that we need to parameterize it over x and y
because they were
the only two free variables in the
definition above
and if we take a look at this function we
see that this is just an application
of the Church to Int body of the function
that we defined before.
We can just substitute that
and we see that in the end we have arrived to our
definition and this was really easy we
didn't really do anything. We just
mechanically
substituted and used a few tricks
from
lambda calculus to arrive to
our answer.
Finally the definition of addition
between two Church numerals
is a function which would be
actually
a Church numeral which will build x
with
the successor function but starting from
the
final representation of y and
therefore giving us the addition of x and y.
Now we have done the addition let's try
now to
define the multiplication. When we think
about multiplying two numbers,
to decimal numbers, what we know
from school is that what we
do is
let's say we want to do
2 times 3 then we want to add together
3 times the number 2
and this is a what this
thing says. Now when we want to do this
with functions, we cannot just
add functions together, but we can compose
them.
The idea is basically the same: we
want to every time
for three times we want to compose
the definition of 2. We can see
it here:
that 6 will be
the composition if we substitute s
with the definition of two, we can see that
six will be just the composition six
times
of the successor function.
Therefore the multiplication will be
defined as a Church numeral again which will take a
successor function
and a zero number.
We will apply a different successor
function to s
which we can call a super
successor which will contain
y exemplars on the successor
function.
Therefore will have the
multiplication.
We can furthermore
clear up this definition
with again few tricks from lambda
calculus and we can just express
it in this way
nicely with composition of x and y. So
that was it
for Church numerals. In the
exercises you will
see a few more tricks that we can do
for example exponentiation
and then there will be on the course
page another link
to further more information about
this representation. Thank you for
listening and happy hacking.